[Applause]
please welcome Will Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening now now I asked to be here
on this part of the show because I love
action movies now it's no disrespect to
all the other kinds of movies but I
happen to love movies that have you know
car chases and explosions and excitement
and the other word I'm looking for
Oh fans yeah well now let's be honest
sometimes action movies don't get the
respect that they deserve but they do
get big budgets and great visual effects
and it's amazing what these artists can
do today in these movies they can take
Brad Pitt turn him into a garden gnome
they can create a beautiful city and
help a crazy man almost just tear it up
and they can show how powerful a man can
be when he ups his daily dose of iron
now they're all great but for
outstanding visual effects the nominees
are the Curious Case of Benjamin Button
Erik Barba Steve pre-birth Dalton and
Craig Baron The Dark Knight Nick Davis
Chris Korbel Tim Weber and Paul Franklin
Iron Man John Nelson
Ben snow dan sudoc and Shane Mahan then
the Academy Award goes to the Curious
Case of Benjamin Button ad baba Steve
Greenberg Dalton and Craig baron
[Music]
[Applause]
accepting the Oscar is Eric Barba
oh my god on behalf of myself Steve
Krieg Burt Dalton and Craig Barron I'd
like to thank the Academy for this
incredible honor I'd also like to thank
Edson Williams and his team at Lola
visual effects and Nathan McGinnis and
his team at asylum as well as all the
other visual effects teams that worked
so hard on this film
I'd like to make thank our amazing team
a digital main my mentor at Albrecht my
wonderful producer Lee Subaru the woman
who is my biggest supporter my wife Romo
Kathleen Kennedy Frank Marshall and Seon
Chafin for trusting we could actually
pull this off Brad Pitt for an amazing
performance and of course David Fincher
forgiving us all the opportunity to work
on this film - my kids Cole and
Nicolette I just like to say work hard
do good work and never give up
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]